é o rap preciso sempre deixo aquecimento
expulsar os garotos hoje o jogo vai ser
porrada colega o lado pessoal do que
falar e andar que seja muito menos é
mais um vídeo e o estádio já que a fj
sabe o que é bom mas você entende dar
que o tj rossi r 21 e agora são seis
pontos não deram certo e eu fui ver o
técnico jorginho do novo e feijão só
vale está aqui roxy você estava em um
fox e um personagem favorito nem nós
vamos ter aqui um encontro de algo
romântico para na sua máxima força e bom
vamos lá eu cansar pessoal do som no
meio do jogo já está bom em alta por
isso e não por aqueles fones mesmos lá
eu vou tentar ser destruídos seguido sem
cortes com vocês gostam de ver que
existiu por ela 321 vai a este encontro
vai ser tão gostoso foxy e [ __ ] ática
e groundforce amanhã então não precisava
de começar já com os filhos né
as pessoas e as pessoas não agüentam
assim o que o objetivo é ganhar 5 a
mesma bosta
já o cônsul cônsul automaticamente
enquanto o foco e já começam logo atrás
de mim como assim
eu não queria morar de cordel assim eu
não saí culpa
comecei não dá já conheço o carro fox se
apronta curso ou até mesmo porque fosse
mulher entregar estas merdas por quê por
quê por quê porque a cabeça foi assim
com o objetivo de adequar logo qual o
oxi está em um modo ou entrar
joão internet não é impossível não tatu
passado isto começa o lugar de frente
olho lá o começo logo viu gosta
agora só o colocou o time pra quê mesmo
isso sem os seus 1200 quer apanhar um
objecto de um objeto a campanha de 2008
portman atenção sem cortes só pra vocês
viram como o google rápido o é
já fui pronto já fui ai que era meu
cozinha gostoso indo anda conosco o que
foi feito foi meu foco é muito rápido
ó paí ó
não dá pra jogar esta bosta não dá é
completamente impossível eu depois virou
tudo sozinho conseguiu passar esta [ __ ]
ninguém consegue ninguém ninguém não dá
não dá não dá tudo veio muito rápido é
bom e rápido não dá pra passar isso é
impossível
nem mesmo os próximos a assinar sete
prédios copa
o meu maninho estado neste momento não
está descarta [ __ ] anda tomando
inclusive já está outra vez vamos pensar
então não vamos acelerar a lanterna
ok não vamos acender um socorrer a
socorrer isso o resultado a equipe do
fundo
nenhum objeto é pelo menos um
agora vamos pensar nós vamos lidar com o
fox e não é será que não se pintaram
sefaz vai pro foxy e pescaram você fosse
o haiti como no original faz nada sem
fred se vai embora será isso não é não
resulta não junta é só fugir então é
isso
anda a tentar fugir mas desta vez quando
o apagado porque é isso que está a
funcionar até agora anda lá consegue
tudo e jexperts do star wars de
suprimentos paranormais de fugir disto
que eu to disse roça não é muito
perigoso esforce não dá não dá eu não
fui rápido o piloto diferente a do jato
suada por isso uma porca já que suada
que estamos nela
é por isso que vocês vão comendo este
ótimo e por isso não é bom vocês um
evento destas figuras não dá
agora outro todo suado socorrer o meu
botafogo ano a sonae sua vez não buscar
mais esta [ __ ] não vou não vou não vou
andar lá encontrei eu fui contra e eu ai
chega não gostaria mais botafogo fosse
espero que o time consiga estói só vamos
ficar porque com este vídeo espero que
vocês tenham gostado deste jogo
magnífico nem dá pra encher um minuto na
em si não se vocês souberem como é que
se passe steel deixem nos comentários
tempo ajudem a fazer alguma coisa que
voltar a ligar ainda pado
e é isso antes que comece quando o
assunto é que o favorito freeman que
aproximam